the most of us takes place in an
alternate earth time line inhabited by
massive unidentified terrestrial
organisms giant monsters of various
shapes sizes and forms each of the film
center around Moana a cryptozoological
organization dedicated to studying the
creatures and their recurring encounters
with the beasts these mutants are now
referred to as titans and each Titan
occupy a specific niche on the earth and
maintain a balance and equilibrium some
titles like Rodin and the lesser Mac
material reside in fiery volcanoes while
others like Mikaela MB Bay and behemoth
are found in dense tropical jungles
since the earth is 70% water it is not
surprising that there are many tyrants
that occupy this ecosystem these are
some of the largest and most terrifying
of them all so let's dive into this list
of all the aquatic or ocean titans of
the monster verse number one Kraken an
undesignated Titan nicknamed Kraken was
the prehistoric giant cephalopod died
kaiju that appeared in Godzilla king of
the monsters deep official movie
novelization as a minor Titan awakening
of the others it is currently unknown if
Kraken appears in the 2019 film Godzilla
king of the monsters but he is canon to
that timeline the Kraken is a giant
squid cryptid antagonistic towards sea
vessels similarly to the Kraken himself
however Kraken is just a nickname for
the undesignated Titan and it is unknown
if he is the actual Kraken legend the
Kraken greatly resembles an octopus or a
squid but with a massive brain protected
by a cone of shell using radiation
signatures and bio sonic emissions
Warnock had discovered an invisible
hibernating Kraken wrapped around the
remains of a nuclear submarine that had
been missing for decades in the Indian
Ocean
they built a secret monarch outpost
around him and nicknamed him the Kraken
as he had not been given an official
name when Ghidorah calls all the Titans
Kraken disguises himself as dead to
break through the containment field
before destroying the classified monarch
outpost and hunting as a bag with the
other awoken Titans like octo ports
Kraken can change the color and balance
of
shell and skin to become virtually
invisible he can also mimic other states
such as death by disguising his own
radiation signature the Krakens brain is
much larger than necessary to control
his body giving him incredible
intelligence surpassing most islands he
is intelligent enough to recognize that
a containment field surrounding him only
works on living Titans something even
more our scientists had not figured out
number two in the violin the violin is
also dubbed as Titanes Leviathan and is
a prehistoric giant aquatic die kaiju
appearing in legendaries 2019 film
Godzilla king of the monsters as a name
appearing on a monitor and it is briefly
mentioned in the novelization the
Leviathan likely refers to the biblical
use in which the Leviathan is a giant
sea creature created by God usually
described as a serpentine crocodile or a
whale this creatures the counterpart to
the behemoth and the leviathans name may
also refer to the definitions of
Leviathan either a large aquatic
creature or something that is very large
and powerful the violin was found in
Nachman Scotland by mana and an outpost
was built around it when Ghidorah calls
the Leviathan breaks free from its
outpost and travels through the Hollow
Earth to the Indian Ocean when he begins
to hunt with the other Titans Leviathan
can travel in and out of Loch Ness with
the use of the Hollow Earth tunnels
possibly coincidentally it is believed
by many Loch Ness monster necked monster
theorists that there are tunnels under
the Loch Ness connected to the see the
violence location in darkness may also
be a reference to Nessie from the 1998
animated series on a scruff hammer movie
number 3 mark Yeager this Titan also
dubbed Titanus McGregor is a prehistoric
giant reptilian die kaiju created by
legendary pictures that appears in
Godzilla king of the monsters the
official movie novelization as a corpse
in the possession of monarch the name
McGregor comes from a type of mermaid in
Greenlandic tradition Titanes McGregor
is believed to have lived in the areas
that these mermaids typically inhabit
near the Arctic but this Titan has been
dead for quite some time too long to
have been alive at a time the Titans
were believed to have been sighted
therefore
presumably named light Anna's McGregor
because of her aquatic nature and flat
face the quality is shaped by these
mermaids mark eager is an aquatic scaly
reptilian Titan similar to Godzilla
about the size of a whale she has a flat
face with her nostrils above her
human-like eyes like some aquatic
mammals and a skull protrudes backwards
shielding her neck in death MA eager
appears Berlant with a skeleton showing
a jagged riff running from her neck to
her abdomen it is unknown to which
tyrant killed machi girl and even Maura
is unaware it was likely one of the
aquatic or amphibious titans of smokey
ager died in the sea but it is also
mentioned that mark eager has Scotch
marks on her scales which makes Godzilla
himself the likely candidate as only he
would have been capable of causing this
damage out of the aquatic Titans number
four Susilo Scylla also dubbed Titanes
Scylla is a prehistoric giant spider
squid crab die kaiju that appears in
legendaries 2019 Godzilla king of the
monsters as a minor Titan eventually
bowing to Godzilla Scylla refers to the
female sea monster from Greek mythology
the daughter of Typhon 1up confirms of
Titanus Scylla is named by the ancient
Greeks who interpreted her as a sea
monster it may also refer to select
genus of swimming crabs as parts of the
Scylla greatly resembled crafts
particularly her legs Scylla may be
derived from speaker another giant
spider died kaiju Scylla also shares her
near similar name with near Scylla and
giant spider monster from Monster Hunter
franchise whose name was also derived
from the Greek monster Scylla is a giant
arachnid like Thailand with black
coloration six very long bony and light
head legs each with two joints and
ending with a claw these legs are strong
enough to tear through solid rock and
small spikes grow out of the first joint
Cilla's head is also surrounded by
several squid like tentacles and unlike
most spiders she only has two eyes her
anatomy is that of a script and not of a
spider allowing her to survive and
thrive under water
Silla is a mnemonic containment facility
in a desert nearby oil rigs in Sedona
Arizona being monitored by monarch and
designated Titanus Silla
she is awoken by the course of a new
alpha Ghidorah and she destroys the oil
rig she was trapped under the ground
along with the other Titans excluding
Godzilla Mothra and calm Scylla is sent
to hunt moving as a pack with the other
Titans news reports later mentioned that
following the Boston battle Scylla has
retreated from humanity and is residing
in a lake according to the reports cell
is having a positive impact on the
environment by slowing down the ice
melting in Antarctica and stabilizing
the world sea levels due to have ping an
inner biology greatly resembling that of
a squid Scylla is capable of surviving
and hunting both on land and in water
number 5 Godzilla in Godzilla awakening
Godzilla is referred to as Mewtwo due to
him not having a name at that time
Godzilla originally gained its name from
the Pacific Islanders who referred to
him as Gojira Ichiro Serizawa also
referred to him as Gojira prior to
Godzilla being formally used but that
set most of the english-speaking
characters eventually started call him
Godzilla over the course of the film's
events
Michael Daughtry later revealed that the
name Godzilla is not the primary name of
the monster but a nickname with the
scientific name used within the film's
universe being Gojira the result in
scientific dubbing of Titanes Gojira for
Godzilla's return the king of the
monsters was given a radically new
origin story that deviates from the
previously established origin of him
being mutated by the hydrogen bomb in
Godzilla awakening the prequel to
Godzilla Godzilla is explained to be an
ancient and ancient life-form from the
Permian period as a planet cool and its
natural atmospheric radiation began to
decrease he adapted to survive various
extinction events by diving deep into
the ocean and consuming the planet's
natural geothermal radiation in a
like state from its molten core until
1945 when the atomic bombings of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki awakened him but
there was another Titan that awakened
along with Godzilla and the name was
shin amaura these two Titans battled
each other for many years all over the
world from the Philippines to causing
the London smog presumably till they
were lured to Bikini Atoll and the
humans detonated the hydrogen bomb in
order to kill both of them
the Shi Nomura title was vaporized by
the sheer heat of the blast but however
Godzilla was unaffected by it and maybe
grew to a larger size because of the
radiation much like when Serizawa
sacrificed himself to detonate the nuke
in order to resurrect Godzilla
anyway Godzilla was theorized by Ichiro
Serizawa to have been the alpha predator
of his oceanic eco system but later on
of the entire world and prevented other
species from overpopulating and
overrunning the world acting as a force
of nature that maintained balance
Godzilla possesses gills and amphibious
lungs so he can stay underwater
indefinitely but he closes his gills
when he's on nan so you can use his
lungs these gills appear to be his weak
points as Godzilla reacts aggressively
whenever he is struck in the gills by
artillery fire or strikes from the
Muto's claws so anyway this is the list
of five aquatic titans that appears in a
monster verse be sure to LIKE share and
subscribe for more videos and do hit the
notification bell for regular and actual
notifications